what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to 90 Day Fiance a gold
digger wants a green card before I start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification Bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in
subscribe to the channel let's get
started hey you guys looking forward to
getting married
yeah why you looked at me first I don't
know I wanted to see your reaction
yeah I'm looking forward to it oh no
I see Russian yeah this is the thing
guys Russian women are more traditional
they are absolutely traditional
um but what they expect out of you is
masculinity and she's like why are you
acting like I'm kind of on her side
already I know everyone's gonna look at
this and be like she's a [ __ ] but
honestly like what are you doing staring
at your girl to answer nah like Russian
women they understand they're supposed
to be beautiful they understand their
they will be submissive from what I
understand and I had a Russian Nanny
they will be submissive to the right cat
but you can't be like a [ __ ] I'm sorry
definitely
don't wash shoes more bags more on the
car there has to be a limit ten thousand
don't make me laugh and I guess be
reasonable so on Pizza tell me a little
bit about what you're looking for I
don't want like a big dress I just want
something straight that would show off
my curves okay
um at one place
why what about price point what are you
comfortable with what is your most
expensive dress
um our most expensive dress would be
forty five thousand dollars is that okay
when George asked me to come to the
states he promised to get me whatever I
want for whatever makes you happy
now that I'm here he keeps telling me
that he can't afford everything and
there are things that are more important
I'm kind of on her side look I'm you
told her that she could get whatever she
wanted
okay yeah that's what you told her don't
promise it you can't do like I'm sorry a
girl will fall in love with a bum but if
you don't but if you pretend to be a
rich guy that's what you think she's
fallen for that's that's kind of like a
girl getting fat on you after you get
her wedding if you didn't promise if you
bought her fat then fine but that's like
buying a skinny girl and then she gets
fat it's the same thing she thinks she's
marrying a rich man you ain't rich
okay I just want to make you happy
don't worry see she's rolling her eyes
and everyone it's because he's kind of
acting like a [ __ ] I'm just being
honest drives at me
[Music]
okay well I think maybe it might be some
time to maybe just go home think about
it
all right honey come on in I've come all
this way to Buddhist George and now he
can't even get me the dress I want
you ready yeah
thank you
wow
you know obviously I don't have 20 000
in cash right now
so it's not my problem
so it's not your problem
yes
and she's just very controlling
um she likes to be bossy
um and I kind of like that I kind of
like her firmness of uh you know her
standing her ground but also standing my
ground too so did he get rid of he
sounds like he grew up in a single
mother home but maybe maybe not why do
you like bossy chicks do you guys like
bossy chicks you like bossy chicks oh
lots of you kind of do he's thinking
about it you like you like okay why do
you like bossy chicks are you a simp
blessing
not a simp not a simp a little bit
you know that's where conflict comes
into play now why did everyone started
getting this Visa why did you bring me
here
you're not ready it's not that I'm not
ready but you're not ready
it's not that I'm not ready I'm just
saying that it's like
[Music]
can you just be straightforward and not
like oh yes yeah I'm straightforward all
right so the straightforward part is
that you want expensive things and
it's you know hard for me to keep up
oh my God she's gonna ruin your life
okay
it's always nice talking to you it's
somebody as smart as me
it's not all that I can say I'm just
saying that it's like it's all happening
so quick so we have to get
everything
blah blah blah that's what I hear
I'm not that wealthy to like compensate
for all of the things that you like that
are really expensive that you want like
right now all those things no I mean
eventually I can get them but you want
everything like today
why can't you
when he tells me that he can't really
afford these expensive things now I feel
like he is breaking promises that he
gave me before I arrived
[Music]
part of me even wants to go back to
Russia
[Music]
look at I mean she's clearly a gold
digger but that's what you signed up
signed her how are you good at
why would you entice a woman with your
money and then
she wants a more Excellence of ring but
I mean there's one thing about being
reasonable and one thing going all over
budget and one thing making me a slave
for the rest of my life
we have to be reasonable
[Music]
happy but I can't get her a ring that's
gonna take me 50 years to pay off
I think we need some time to think maybe
I will be able to make him get something
more expensive
church and I need to have a talk about
money he made me a lot of promises and
now I'm here and he's not coming through
so you're basically saying that you're
just dating me because I can buy you
things
yes
[Music]
okay that's what I say Russian women
don't play he's trying to like gold
digger guilt her and she's like yeah
that's yeah that's not right I don't
think I don't think that's love
what
so basically you're saying if I can't
provide
I'm worthless to you
I don't understand what's wrong about it
if I was ugly and fed would you be
dating me
that's what I say Russian women they
understand their roles she's like look
it I
she might be a bit delusional okay she
very well may be but she told him what
it was and I respect people that tell
him what it is
[Music]
if you were who you are
yes yeah
looks don't always have anything to do
with it
oh my God shut up you think her looks
got her to America yeah yeah I think the
boobs yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
so what if
I buy the ring you want to buy the
expensive dress I give you like the most
amazing wedding in the world and
something happened say I get hurt or
something and I can't work
and what then you're just gonna leave me
it's just an old women this is what it
comes with she's gone nasiki gotta
ghosted bye
you tell a Russian woman you can't
provide I'm beautiful and
I like nice clothes nice shoes nice
purses so
[Music]
I expect him to pay for all that
you keep wanting more and more
like when is the end
[Music]
after you want some you're gonna want
something else and after you get that
you're gonna want something to know
yeah like there's never going to be an
end to it
[Laughter]
Rock about dating women like this but he
brought her there he brought her that
like what why'd you break her
I can make some sacrifices on my end but
really if I buy those things like I'm
gonna just regret it because I'm only
making sacrifices for the person that I
love but if they don't want me back then
why should I
make that sacrifice
[Music]
what
see
you get into the driver's side door she
broke phones
plural
I tried calling her she uh
she erased my phone she's very
controlling I can't talk I'll call you
back no
[Music]
I'm literally making a deal for 15
and you're really [ __ ] up
throughout all this guys smash or pass
on the girl smash smash
nope here what about the first one the
blind chick the last 90 day passed but
yeah that's what I mean it doesn't
matter how sweet you are if you don't
pass the men's bar you're not even
getting in the door swear to God men
will take a [ __ ] of a 120 hot chick
before they take a 250 anything they
don't care that that woman can make his
life a living hell but if she looks good
enough they'll deal with it it might not
be their first choice but you think that
guy wants a man on a girl on his looks
level come on
Chicago
when you have money that's when she
spreads her life yeah walk away because
you're a little girl you need to grow up
you don't know anything I feel like he's
suffering I'm not gonna let him fisa
destroy him he's lying to me he's hiding
things for me I'm not going to screw
myself over just because you want to be
happy
oh oh okay well I hope they break up
look here um as much as she is a gold
digger he brought her over I don't know
what you're doing bringing over a
Russian chick they they you tell I guess
I'm sad you tell a Russian women you
can't provide oh my God she does not
care you are dead to her uh but let me
know what you guys think maybe I'm wrong
let me know in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible